well sheriff joe lombardo is making it
official the clark county sheriff
is now vying to become the republican
candidate in the race for governor
the i-team's david charns was at today's
announcement and has more on what this
means david
a christian sheriff lombardo now the
third republican jumping in the race to
try to compete against democratic
governor steve sisilak in 2022
lombardo making the announcement at
rancho high school where he graduated
now he promises if he becomes governor
to not raise any taxes
fight for gun rights and break the
democrats one party control in carson
city
he says he is the hard-line conservative
in this race
and wants to be the law and order
candidate
do you see what's going on across the
united states we're seeing a
proliferation of crime
a significant increase in crime
especially violent crime
and i know how to fix that i i
understand it i've been in the
in the law enforcement community and
it's been my profession and
understanding
for 30 plus years now while all over
violent crime is down year over year in
the valley murders and property crime
are up
in metro's jurisdiction we asked
governor steve sisilak last week about
the race keeping in mind the big issue
between who he eventually runs against
will likely be over his handling of the
pandemic
it's easy to sit back and be a monday
morning quarterback
uh you know when you come to these
situations this state
faced a pandemic that if it comes once
in a century
now the governor says he believes he
made all the right calls
i asked sheriff lombardo if he's seeking
former president trump's endorsement he
says he's not seeking it but
would take it if it does come down the
road keep in mind though this primary
election isn't scheduled until next
summer so
we've got a long ways to go and possibly
more people jumping in the race i'm
david charns 8 news now